eddie van halen has died after a long  battle with cancer  the legendary guitarist was 65. on  tuesday his son wolfgang shared the  heartbreaking news on twitter writing  he was the best father i could ever ask  for every moment i  shared with him on and off stage was a  gift  my heart is broken and i don't think  i'll ever fully recover from this  loss i love you so much pop the rock  icon was the co-founder of the 70s band  van halen  and is best known for their hit song  jump  [Music]  and it was eddie's famed guitar work  that was the focal point  of their legacy the band won a grammy in  1992 for  best hard rock performance for their  album for unlawful  carnal knowledge and van halen was  inducted into the rock and roll hall of  fame in 2007.  eddie married actress valerie bertinelli  in 1981  they eventually split and their divorce  was finalized in 2007.  he is survived by wolfgang the son he  shares with bertinelli  and his wife actress janie liszewski